- Hello, good afternoon.
Thank you for making time to come join me.
Talk about, as you can
see from the title slide,
Reimagining Business
Processes with Joule Agents.
I'm Walter Sun and I lead
the AI product engineering team at SAP.
So just to give you, put
everyone on the same page,
I just want to share a high level diagram
of what we do in business AI at SAP.
I'll start bottoms up.
At the bottom is applications.
For those of you now that
are familiar with SAP,
we have products across
all lines of businesses
like human capital management,
we have success factors,
for travel, we have Concur,
for procurement, we have Ariba,
and then for ERP, we have S4,
which is used by most of
the Fortune 500 companies.
All this is supported
with embedded AI features.
And so we build features
that come out of the box.
If you get business OCR, you
get document understanding,
when you scan a receipt for
Concur, that comes from AI.
That's kind of embedded
in all the solutions.
What we've done is we've
gone a step beyond that
and I'll talk about that today with Joule.
Above that, first of all, the data layer,
we have a product called
the Business Data Cloud.
This product is to allow you
to bring all your data to one place
and by virtue of it being the same place
allows you to get insights
across all your lines of
businesses at one place.
And above that is all the
AI that we build on top.
So Joule, as I mentioned,
is our AI co-pilot,
if you're not familiar with that.
And the idea with Joule is that
it connects with natural language
to each of your business processes.
And the beauty of that is it makes it
quick and easy for new hires.
So if a new hire at your
company and you use SAP,
they can use natural language to execute
without needing to
understand the OS very well
or the UX very well.
And so for instance, if you say you joined
and you want to take a vacation
for the holidays, it's December now,
say, "Hey, I want to take
like three days of vacation
before Christmas."
You can do that with
natural language in Joule
and it goes into success factors
and makes that change for you
rather than you understanding
where you need to go.
So that actually is kind
of the first step of Joule.
natural language to processes, right?
And actions beyond that,
you know, is agents.
And agents is a big topic.
You heard Matt Garman talk
a lot about this morning.
We'll talk more about it today as well
and how we are using it at SAP.
But with that, each of
the lines of business,
as you see here, finance,
procurement, supply chain,
each of them have agents
that you can interact with.
The additional value is that these agents
can interact across different
lines of businesses.
And that's kind of the
value add of having SAP
having applications across all lines.
For instance, if you are,
let's say a business person
and you wanted to figure
out how to book a trip
to visit your top clients,
you would have to access your CRM tool,
which we have a product called CX.
And then once you find that information,
you actually go to a travel
tool, which would be Concur.
And so with multi-agent communication,
you can do all that in one place.
And I'll talk a little bit
about how all that works.
But I'll first kind of mention
like the motivation, right?
You know, we all talk about agents,
everyone talks about agents.
How do I motivate, how
do we motivate this,
this topic in case you're not
convinced this is valuable.
If you go 15 years ago or
maybe even 10 years ago,
you might go on a trip.
Let's say you're in LA,
you want to come to "re:Invent" in Vegas,
you want to travel, you get a map,
or you might go to AAA
or a local travel company
and say, "Give me a map
and an itinerary for how
to go from LA to Las Vegas."
Then you go to Palm Springs or whatever
and you go through this detailed map
and then you get it all
figured out like a week before
and then you leave like say
Monday, come here, right?
Yesterday, you come here.
What you do also, this
is the same thing you do
with applications in the
past, as I mentioned,
if you want to book a...
I'll use this example again and again,
if you want to visit your top customers,
you actually would first
find out who they are.
So you go to your CRM tool,
you find out who they are
and then you say, okay, you
talk to your administrator
or somebody or a travel agency say
"I need to have book
trips to these locations,
how will I make it work?" Right?
So the idea is you plan ahead
and then you execute, right?
With agents, you can actually
do it basically real time
the same way you do travel
now with GPS, right?
So you go on, let's say
if you were from in LA
and you wanted to come to Las Vegas,
you would probably not even need
to spend days and days planning.
You would just say, "I'll put in my GPS,
we'll see what happens."
And that's not actually even worse.
It's actually even better
than it was 10, 15 years ago
because 10, 15 years ago,
you plan it two weeks ago
and then let's say a road
closes like over Thanksgiving,
you don't know that and
you get stuck, right?
GPS gives you real time
traffic, real time conditions
and it can readjust you by the same way.
By the same token, this
example I gave you for agents
maybe two weeks ago, you figured out
who your top five customers are,
customers, A, B, C, and D.
And you also want to bring
a couple of your colleagues
along, Jane and John.
But by the time you travel,
maybe John's transferred
a different division,
maybe one of your top five
customers is out of town,
maybe customer A happens
to be at "re:Invent"
and they can't meet with you.
So you actually have the
ability to use agents
that dynamically also
adapt to the needs as well.
So it's a very analogy I
like is that basically you,
we all know how we used the maps before
and how we do maps now,
for many of you who haven't
started using agents,
you do a lot of things
manually now, piece by piece,
in the future you can use
agents to do them all together
and also dynamically
in a way that actually
is optimal as well.
And so the question is
why are agents special?
I think the first thing
is idea of reasoning.
A lot of people aren't super comfortable
with the idea that machines
or systems can reason, right?
But the reality is that, you know,
having this ability
brings a lot more power.
The same reason idea, if you hire,
I used the analogy that agents
are like junior assistants
that you hire,
you hire a college graduate,
the first few days or few
months they're on a job,
you don't want them to
think on their own too much
because it's risky and things can happen.
So you tell them what to do
and you follow them closely, right?
But after time you let
them do their own thing.
And so the idea is that
you let them reason later
initially you don't let
them reason at all, right?
And this is the same with machines,
you know, in the past we
don't let them reason,
we just say here's task A, task B, task C,
complete that, right?
A give me a list of top
customers, I have that,
B, given these customers,
find me flights to these locations, right?
Now you can say these agents
can actually reason and say
if you want to know who
your top customers are,
you want to visit them,
you can contact a travel
agent, which is Concur for us.
And beyond that, these
agents also can reason
about what's logical.
I'm not going to book four
trips to Chicago, New York,
Los Angeles, and San Francisco
and Miami the same day
because it's not logical, right?
These systems, I've learned
basic logic of mapping
and locations and these type of things
can help you apply logic
and get the right answer.
And this is just an easy
example of visually map,
you know, geo mapping.
But this actually works
in complex business processes as well.
These models are trained on so much data
and so much information
that you know what's logical.
If you want to, let's say buy
a ton of inventory from Asia
over Black Friday and shipping
and get it ready for the holidays,
the system will tell you, in the past,
other companies have tried this,
it's not worked out too well, right?
It takes much more longer
because weather conditions are
worse in the fall, late fall
people are all buying
inventory at that time.
So basically these systems
can help correct errors
that you don't know.
And the idea is that it can plan,
it can also take action as well.
And all of this is kind of the
new age of what's happening
and it makes it a lot easier
for us to get things done.
And so I talked a little
bit about what we do,
but you know, the very first slide,
I gave a quick overview
of the application layer,
the data layer and the Joule agents.
But I think the point I guess
I want to talk about the top
is that these agents
iterated around themselves
and we also have analytics agents as well.
These analytics agents can analyze
how your agents are performing,
making sure you do better.
We have RPA agents that
help you automate as well.
We have also system trigger
agents that you can follow rules
so that these aren't reactive agents
but they're proactive as well.
Meaning that they can say,
"Hey, when I an email from
our CEO, do X, Y, and Z."
Versus like wait for you to use Joule
or use the chat window to make a request.
And so the idea also is,
I mentioned before that
because we have all lines of businesses,
you can actually build
agents across all lines.
You have data across
all lines of businesses,
so the systems understand all of that.
And by having that full context,
you get a lot more done.
And beyond that, suppose
you have your own,
let's say an old org chart app
that you built 25, 30 years ago.
We have Joule studio that lets you extend
and build up on top of
what's in our system.
So the idea is that you
can extend what's available
and still use Joule to access
more than just what's in SAP.
And all this happens, this
is just an example like
how you can apply questions that actually
can answer very specific
things in your company.
Show me my sales reps by revenue.
And so you get these top five sales reps.
Obviously if you ask a
large language model,
this public model,
you're not going to get
any information like this
because there's no information
about your company, right?
So all of this is carefully
grounded in your data
and that's an important part of me,
I think you understand the grounding is
but the idea that a language model
is trained on public data,
but not all data you have is public,
models aren't run real time
so you need grounding that
gives you real time data, right?
If you ask about what happened
in today's keynote from Matt Garmin,
you need a model that has
some grounding of news
that can get that information.
You also need for your company
run information that's private.
You know, you have your, let's
say the most common thing
I talk about is your vacation policy.
Every company has a different policy
and yours is even different
from your colleagues
based on how long you've
been there, right?
So basically it needs to be grounded in
what the company policies are
and also needs to be
grounded in your profile.
All that information is
provided automatically in Joule.
So now I'll talk about
basically our vision
and goals for agents.
It's basically three pronged.
The first thing is we want to make sure
that there are agents available
to you out of the box.
So we want to empower
you with prebuilt agents,
but as I mentioned, you
might not have everything
you need already out of the box.
You might have something
you want to use yourself.
So we're democratizing the ability for you
to develop your own agents
and plug them into the system.
That's the second mission.
And then third mission is that
we're also not restricting
you to the SAP ecosystem.
We know that you may have
other product providers
like we're here with AWS at "re:Invent",
you might use you know, Agent
Space or other technologies.
And so the idea is that
you would actually,
we have this technology we
apply with agent to agent,
it lets you work across
agent technologies.
And so I'll talk about as a third mission.
So starting with the first
mission, we have pre-built agents
and now 25 agents are
available already in production
and we have 15 more going to
production by end of the year,
end of this month.
And so you can sort of see a list of them
you have things like accounts receivable,
dispute resolution, and as I mentioned,
many of these are system
triggered dispute resolution.
You don't want to go to the machine
and say what disputes do I have?
Rather, if a dispute happens,
it comes in by email,
you want to be alerted by it, right?
So with these agents that
are system triggered as well,
that can act proactively
to you and your needs.
And here, I'll show two examples.
One is a catalog optimization agent.
A lot of people who are in retail
have a catalog of the inventory of items,
but these inventory items
update every day, right?
You might have a new version of a product,
you might sell out of a product,
you might want to transition
product A to product B,
you know, equivalent.
And the whole idea behind this is
that it's very difficult
to do this manually.
And so a catalog optimization agents
an agent that helps
you update in real time
what's happening based off
of your incoming orders
and outgoing sales.
And so we found that by using this agent,
people are reducing time to
translate catalog data by 70%.
And we also found that people are spending
65% less time maintaining assets.
And you can imagine that's
the case for a retail company
if any of you are in that business.
The other example is
basically accounting accruals.
Accruals is the idea
that there's something
that's kind of that's building up
but you haven't been billed yet.
Like you have a credit card
bill, you pay every month
during the month you
accrue charges, right?
Which you can see, but in some cases,
you can't see quite as readily.
For instance, an example that
you may see is electricity.
Your electricity bill, you use
electricity at home every day
and at the end of the
month or so you get billed
and typically you can assume it's linear,
but you know as the weather
gets colder in the fall
you might use more electricity.
And so basically having a agent
that helps you understand your policy,
understanding historical transactions
and using that to extrapolate
what your numbers are
quite valuable.
And I'll show you a
demonstration for this,
but just to show you,
customers have used this
on 80% time reduction
in calculating the accruals
and a 50% reduction time
to review the amounts
and posting entries.
So I'll show you an example.
This actually the
accruals agent in action.
And so there's two
unprocessed accruals here
and let me just show you the first one,
This one, you look into this video
and I'm trying to make,
keep it more interactive
by showing a few demos
right here you're saying
I have this one item that's
not paid, not accrued yet.
I want to know what it is.
And so you can sort of see the reasoning,
the reasoning tells
you what it's been told
in the system and I'll
show you in a minute,
the workflow says go to
your policy documents
and figure out how we do accruals.
And the way we do accruals is two things.
One is you extrapolate by
based on number of days,
but you also have a year
over year adjustment.
And so that basically this
accruals agent does that.
And you'll see the flow chart here
and you see the flow chart
here as you look below
is accounting policy
handbook at the very bottom,
the first thing.
And over here you have the
posted accruals as well.
So basically you have your
company policy as rounding,
you have your post-it actual accruals
and you take the actual accruals,
your policy and the rules
and come up with a a new number, right?
And this is kind of the recommendation
and if you're happy
with the recommendation,
you just say okay, and you're done.
Obviously you'll always
have human in the loop.
So if you're not happy with the number,
you can always adjust it.
But it tells you with transparency
how it came up with the 63.25 number.
Now that beyond just doing the math,
you can see this other case of like
looking and solving
more difficult problems.
This one has a error, you
see the red box on top.
And the problem is there's
no cost center applied
to this particular example.
So what you want to do is
say, okay, let me use Joule,
which is our AI copilot
and ask and find out
what is the cost center.
This happens to me a lot myself for real.
People say, Hey Walter,
can I use your cost center for something?
And I have a cost center,
but I don't know off the top of my head,
Joule knows what it is.
You say, "Hey, help me solve this problem,
this particular one doesn't
have a cost center."
And immediately Joule says,
"I recommend you use the
cost center for this value
and this value is potentially
your cost center."
And you say yes, do you
want to do this or no,
again, you're in charge.
And once you say yes, you
actually get it applied.
And then it says, okay,
now that I have it applied,
everything else is fine.
Should I post this accrual?
And you say yes, you go
ahead and you're done.
And so we saw two cases
we just talked about
of the accruals agent,
one is taking following company policy,
the other is actually fixing an error
that was in the system.
So that's kind of just two examples of
how you can use the accruals agent.
And so the value of this, as I mentioned,
is proactive alerting, right?
You are alerted in this example
and over a course of three minutes,
two or three minutes, we
just did this together,
we figured out how to
solve a couple of cases.
So you're proactively alerted of issues.
Maybe you have a thousand different cases,
only two at issue.
You can automate these tasks
as you can sort of see a lot
of this work is automated.
And finally, it augments
your business decision making, right?
It helps you decide and
fix problems quickly
rather than requiring you to read through
the case every time.
If you can imagine, as I mentioned,
I don't know if you have the same problem,
but if you asked to add
your cost center every time,
like one time a week,
you can do that 50, look up
information 50 times a year,
a system can do that very quickly.
And this is one simple
example of how it works.
So basically that's
kind of using the agent
for business process.
You can also have to
mention earlier use agents
to improve your processes.
And so we have Signavio,
which lets you understand
how your businesses are running.
And so we have an agent
mining in Signavio,
it's a tracing agent for
decisions and actions,
it flags, bottlenecks, determines
if you're not compliant
and it also monitors
and optimizes the value.
So this is basically a workflow
that lets you evaluate the processing
how your agents are doing.
So I think one thing I
was just going to say is
that we have five main processes
or principles for agent development.
One is you want to design
for business outcomes.
We don't want to design agents
that you never use, right?
We want to find agents
that you need the most.
And so we talk to customers
and you can also tell me
or anyone you know from SAP like
what agents do you need
built for our products?
And that helps you get,
helps us bring value to you.
Accelerating time to value.
This is the whole idea that we don't,
a lot of things are very arduous at work.
How do you make sure you get things done
more and more quickly?
Streamlining the engagement through Joule.
This is the point I showed
you earlier in this demo
where you actually are using Joule
and engaging very quickly with accruals
and other things without
having to go through the UX,
taking many, many steps.
Reinforcing human trust
and accountability.
This is important, right?
Responsible AI and AI
ethics are a big key part
of any kind of AI work and
it's the same with AI agents.
You saw in the process that
when we talked about accruals,
we gave rules as to how we decided
on the 63.25 euros, right?
It said hey, extrapolate number of days
but also take an increase
of x percent every year
because of inflation or
cost of goods, right?
And so we have full accountability
and you have full trust in
terms of how we're actually
providing the answers to
you through these systems.
And lastly, I mentioned the
word democratizing development.
This is kind of the second principle
and it kind of segues our fifth principle
is basically how do we
make it easy for you
to use access agents?
So the first part was accessing
out of the box agents.
That's hopefully easy and fast to use.
If you haven't tried
it, please try it out.
The second thing is saying,
"Hey look, I actually
have my own needs but
you didn't satisfy them,
you showed me 40 agents,
but I don't really want to, you know,
I need something else."
And so we can let you extend and build
and also share that
information to other people.
And that's do both of this
product called Joule Studio.
In Joule Studio, and I'll
show you another demo here.
You actually are taking third box AI agent
and Joule skills builder.
And so basically you use Joule
Studio to create a project
and you can sort of see
here, you want to actually,
and in a matter of two minutes
you can actually build this agent.
And so the idea is you say okay,
create an AI agent and then you type in
what you want it for.
Logistics agent is the
one I'm showing you here.
How do I create a logistics agent?
Well you give an explanation
and that's basically
the prompting you give
to the LLM on the left hand side
saying this is how you should do it.
And for logistics agents,
we need to actually collect information
about what packages you're looking for
and then you need to
give me details about,
we'll give them details about
what the status of the package.
And so you need to add documents
and this here it tells you,
shows you how you can add
the right information.
Let's say shippers, you need
to get the input from shippers
and then you create some skills.
And why have here basically
transportation skill
where you create, you
see a flow chart here
that's being built and in this flow chart
we need to add different
components, right?
And so for each component we talk about
what inputs do you have?
That was the first thing it did.
I know it's going kind of fast,
but the goal is basically this,
the short of it is you get the inputs,
basically the packages are coming in
and the outputs that you want.
And once you get the output,
you also want to figure out like
where do you get information from here?
And this is transportation processes.
This transportation
process looks up externally
the status of different packages.
Like if you go to your
shipper, FedEx, DHL, whatever,
look up the status and
after you fetch the status,
you also want to report it back.
So you create this confirmation message
and this message is
customizable by you as well.
And you type in the format you want
and now you have your flow.
Once the flow is completed
you can actually double
check and test it out,
which is what I'll show you here.
You do a test and you
can say using Joule again
and it says this is a test case,
this is looking at a
Joule test of logistics
and you ask, you know,
find the best carrier
for urgent product and it says
give me some more details.
So you say I'm going to ship
from Chicago to Pittsburgh.
And then tells you, okay,
given that what you want,
the recommended provider is DHL.
And so you can sort of see,
you can test the agent you built.
And over the course of about
three minutes of this video,
you actually built a new
agent to handle logistics.
And so you can sort of
see if you're at a company
and you want to add new
capabilities like this,
it's very easy to do and build you on top
of what we have already.
So now you have a 41st agent
on top of the 40 that we provide
and it's included in the library there.
So that's kind of an example.
Over the course of a few minutes,
you can build your own agents.
And so the goal behind this is that
you can actually extend easily
what you need to build here.
So on top of that though,
you say well, well let me
first show you how it works.
so basically by extending on this,
you have our applications in
the light blue to the bottom,
you actually go up to the
SAP building of Joule studio,
which is where we showed you
building your own custom agents.
And now your custom agents
can interact above into
the purple section.
You see the arrows up,
you actually fully immersed
into the other agents
that Joule has.
So in the future, if you're
using one of the Joule agents,
the supply chain and you ask
a question about package,
it knows that you've created,
once you registered this logistics agent,
hey you're actually asking
about the status of a package.
This logistics agent has
the skills to find out
what the answer is, it'll call
it and give you the answer.
So this is just going to show you how
you can quickly integrate into our system.
So I mentioned extensibility,
what I showed you is the
third one, custom agents,
how you build additional agents.
You actually have different ways,
different levels of customization
from the least or most simple is basically
you can add configurations,
you may have specific
parameters you change
and you can do that.
The second one is using it to your studio
to add custom fields.
Field extensibility may be
like we have city, state, zip,
maybe you have county you
want to add to your system.
Doing that's pretty easy.
A little more difficult
is what we did here
where custom agents, which
still is pretty easy to build.
And finally the far right
is Joule Studio's third party agents
and this is kind of leveraging A2A
and I'll talk about that in a bit
and how we connect there.
But before I do that,
I want to talk about how in
the process of building agents,
we can also have agents
also build agents as well.
And this is kind of an
interesting thought of like
how do you have your agents
assist you to build new agents?
And what you're seeing here is basically
the way it works is you
basically create a system
that you interview people
that are product experts.
So you ask the question and says,
Hey, what do you do to to order
new laptops or new machines?
This person says the process
starts with a laptop request.
Basically you manage your
performance checks sequentially
and then it's approved or not approved.
And so you can see after
you say natural language,
we can create a process
visualization of that.
There's a flow, right?
Person asks a question,
I check to see if they're eligible
and I check to see the budget
and then I check to
see if it's sustainable
and they're done.
And so basically in natural language,
this person was able to,
John, here in this example,
was able to give you the process
and a way to order a
laptop from your company.
So that's the first step.
After you do interviews here,
we do two interviews with John
and another person named Max.
We can evaluate to see
how the process works.
So we interview multiple people
and there's a slight difference.
And this one you'll see
that in the sustainability,
Max didn't comment about it, right?
So we can actually
quickly could talk to Max
and say, what's your sustainability
policies at the same as John's.
If it is, then we're done there.
After that you can go
to the tool mapping case
basically saying, okay,
now you have a flow,
but how do you know if someone's eligible?
So this eligibility check has a question,
I don't know what tool to use.
Well every company has
their own database, right?
And so here you can say, okay,
open this eligibility check
and pick the right tool necessary.
So here you have a tool called
asset master data verifier.
And with that tool, it can
check within the company
if you're eligible to buy a laptop,
whether it be a three year policy,
a two year policy,
whatever your company does.
So now you have this tool that says,
okay, now this tool processes
access this product.
This is where you go to
to determine eligibility.
And then when you finish this process,
you go to the next step of
basically looking at these agents
and saying, this is now available for use.
So through interviews,
through cleaning up,
making sure all policies fit,
you can actually add this other agent
and it's added to this list
of other agents that exist.
So again, this is another
way to build agents.
You have agent out of the box,
you have agents you can build
yourself with Joule studio
and you can also interview
and talk to people, personas
and get agents built
automatically this way as well.
So many different ways to do it.
And so in this example
what I just showed you
is basically this interview process
at leads to understanding of the process.
And then you need to actually
help map the tools, of course,
sometimes the systems don't
know which tools you use,
but once you have all that together,
your customized agent is done.
So this is just another way to do it.
Okay, so then as I mentioned,
these are ways you can build
with the SAP ecosystem,
but sometimes you may
want to use other systems.
You know, we know that
people use other agents,
other systems and we don't
want to force you to use SAP,
we want to make sure you're
as productive as possible
working together with
your partner companies.
And so this whole idea of
multi-agent collaborations
has evolved over time.
I think many of you know what MCP is.
Have you heard MCP?
Raise your hand if you have heard of it?
I think some of you heard of it.
Most of you heard of it.
It's basically a way to standardize
a protocol of access, right?
You can wrap up MCP server
around some of your APIs,
you get access, people
can access it quickly.
The next thing was a task handover, right?
Agents, instead of
agents providing actions,
they can be tools as well.
Meaning that if I'm asked,
let's say earlier in the CX
customer service example,
if I'm asked to book a
flight for my customers,
the CRM tool doesn't do that.
So CRM tool says, I actually
know another tool, Concur,
that actually can do it for you.
So these agents can
actually hand over tasks.
And then finally at last
point is the collaboration
where you actually, you
have a CRM agent talking to
a travel agent and they
can go back and forth
and you say, "Hey look, I need to go
to New York, Chicago, and LA."
And the travel agent says,
"Here are the flights."
And this person comes back
and says, "Oh, you know,
I actually checked, this
customer's not available that day.
Those customer's traveling."
And so it can be a back and forth.
It's not just a one shot process,
it's an iterative process
where you negotiate
agent to agent,
the same way humans would as well.
You can imagine, the way I tell
people is like 10 years ago,
as you can imagine, your CRM,
your sales specialist talking
to your one of your travel agents,
but the interaction in the email chain,
which could be four or
five different turns
can be done all automatically now.
And that's kind of the amazing power
of these technologies, right?
Basically instead of
being a single shot of
book me a flight to LAX comes back, says,
"Hey, I can't do that,
there's no flights there."
Usually conversation's over, right?
But in real life with humans, you say,
"Oh, okay, I can't go to LAX,
I can go to Burbank or
somewhere else in LA."
And so basically this
whole iterative process
happens with agent to
agent communications.
And so how does this work
practically speaking and interoperability?
We have inbound agents and outbound agents
meaning that people can
use access our agents
from the outside
and we can actually have bring in agents
the other way as well.
So in this diagram, you can
look at the full circle.
Let's look at the bottom portion first.
Basically if you have an agent
you built for yourself in your company
and you want to put in into Joule,
we talked a little bit
about how you do it, right?
You have created a server
and the Joule skill picks it up.
And so in Joule says, okay,
I know you have extra skill capability,
we can now access it.
I mentioned our org
chart agent or something,
you can create something
like that yourself.
We can access it inbound to
us using the A2A protocol.
On the other hand,
we're in the process of
building the agent gateway,
which lets us enumerate
all the agents we have.
So if you're, let's say, you
have agent in orchestrating,
you're orchestrating a process
and you want to actually access, let's say
our Concur travel agent,
you can actually make a call and say,
"Hey, I need to travel book a flight,
can I get Concur to respond?"
In that case, our agent gateway
just gives you information right away
because you know what agent you want.
If it's more complicated saying,
"Hey, I actually have a
more difficult question
of supply chain, but I know
that SAP can solve it."
It would then call Joule
and Joule would help
orchestrate the process.
So there's two ways to
access our agents inbound.
One is if you know exactly what you want,
then you can use the agent gateway
and it's call it what you want,
but if you don't know what you want,
Joule can help orchestrate the process.
And that's kind of how
interoperability works.
And, and the value behind this is that
there's just a whole lot more opportunity
where you can actually access agents
through an entire ecosystem
of many, many companies.
And we're actually working on,
we're not letting people
who are supporting this,
but a lot of people are
supporting this A2A protocol.
And so it makes it a lot easier
for end customers to get things done.
And so, you know, in terms of like
extending code base frameworks,
I would mention that, you know,
since we're here at "re:Invent,"
we're working with AWS in several things.
One example, one thing we're working on
is using Strands SDK,
connecting with Light LLM.
Light LLM is particularly
good at using connecting
with many different core
base agents form frameworks.
And one them is Strands.
So you can sort of see on the Kyma Runtime
and on the left hand light blue box,
you have your Strands agent,
which I've highlighted in red.
And so Strand agents
works with the Light LLM
and then it connects
to the right hand side
with this purple box encircle
is generative AI hub,
which is where we
actually have our 40 plus
large language models you can access
amongst the 40 large language models,
we have some proxy outside
and the bottom right you sort
of see the Amazon bedrock.
We actually proxy and
access Amazon Nova models
as well as the Anthropics Claude models
and others Titan as well.
And so we actually have the ability
to actually connect to 40 plus LLMs,
including all the ones that AWS supports.
And so this is kind of an example of
how you can actually integrate
different code-based frameworks.
This one's AWS Strands.
Now I want to show you
how we use AgentCore,
which is AWS's agent framework
and Joule together, an A2A,
and this is a real demo that was created.
And the idea is basically we're looking at
how we look at different
disaster relief scenarios.
In this scenarios, there's an area,
there areas that have
been affected by floods
and there's an AgentCore agent
that understands information on floods
and we want to figure out
how to help with the relief effort, okay?
So the question is like
what regions have been affected by floods?
And so it quickly, you
can sort of see here
in the Joule analysis, Joule orchestration
that says there's an
Amazon AgentCore agent
that can do this.
So by A2A, we call Amazon AgentCore agent
and ask about the flooded regions
and it gives you Miami and a
bunch of other regions, okay?
And so the idea behind this
is that we could pick any of these,
but let's suppose we
want to focus on Miami.
So we can say, okay, Miami is
the one that's most affected.
So let's spend a little
bit time looking more there
so we can ask more questions about it.
So we can ask AgentCore again,
"Hey, tell me about
what help do they need,
what supplies do they need?"
And so then it comes back and says,
"You know, some of the things they need."
And gives you a whole list in a second.
But one thing they need is water.
And we're going to focus on water.
This is running in real time.
So I mean, it's demo.
So it'll take a second or two.
So you see here it gives
you different issues
of like life jackets, water,
cleaning drinking water,
mobile command centers.
But we'll focus on water.
But before we focus on the water,
I want to say, if you're not
sure actually using this,
we can actually go underneath the hood
and take a look at what's happening.
And this is what I'll show
you next that if you look,
you can sort of see that
AgentCore agents are activated,
this is looking at CloudWatch,
if you use that for AWS,
you can sort of see the
calls are being made.
Four calls have been made
there, so calls have been made.
So we're actually indeed working
within Joule and AgentCore
and now let's look at
clean drinking water, okay?
let's figure out how to
handle clean drinking water.
So far Joule's been using AgentCore.
Now we're going to use S/4 with an SAP
to actually look at provider suppliers,
look at S/4 and determine
which of my approved suppliers
can support Miami this point in time.
We get two responses back saying
these are two possible suppliers.
The first one has been
approved for specific reasons,
second one's good too as well.
And I can say, look, I
given the supplier ID,
we'll just make an order
for Oriental Labs Inc.
And so I says, okay,
place a purchase order
and then the order's made,
and again, this is all a real demo,
meaning that we actually
did connect with AgentCore
and to show you that we did that
we can actually go into our
purchase order product UX
and see you do a search
for that purchase order.
You'll see it's there.
You see it's there.
And so the main goal is that showing you
that you can actually have different
agents collaborate with each other, right?
And so this is just a quick
demo to show you how it works.
Okay, so we talked about agents
and I think that managing
agents can be easy,
it can be hard,
people might say, well how
come, how does this work?
Some of these demos are obviously easy
because they're few agents in a universe.
So managing single agents easy, right?
Let's say have a sourcing agent,
there's like one monkey in the zoo, right?
But then all of a sudden
you have other agents.
When you have other agents,
it gets a little more crazy, right?
Like it's the same idea.
If I say, hey, book a flight, right?
And I have a Concur agent,
nothing else, right?
But if I actually have a bunch
of different travel agencies,
then you need to figure out book a agent
using my company's preferred agency,
Concur, whatever, right?
And so basically you
need a little bit more,
but in general, how do you handle this?
Well, we actually have a process to handle
these wild agents by
having a zoo of sorts.
And basically this AI Agent Zoo, we call,
is basically the idea that we organize
through a LeanIX agent hub,
different agents in the different groups,
finance, human resources,
supply chain, customer experiences.
And so by doing so, we can actually help
provide better context and segmentation
to make it easier for you
to access your agents.
And so by using this tool, as
I mentioned, LeanIX Agent Hub,
you can access all the
agents in one place,
but not just SAP agents.
It also can access third party agents
and custom agents as well.
So you build your own agent,
custom agents are there,
you have a third party agent,
we talked about AgentCore or anyone else,
we can also have it there as well.
So all of that is available there.
Okay?
So we're trying to make
it as easy as possible.
You know the reason I'm
talking about making it easy
is you can sort of imagine,
in the initial case of a few pages,
it's kind of like when the
internet started, right?
A couple of URLs came out.
I don't know if you remember,
you probably memorized them.
Maybe you go to espn.com
for sports or whatever,
there are three or four sites,
you just memorize the URL.
But after it became a thousand URLs
you went to search engines, right?
And this is the same thing with agents.
Initially you might use like three or four
of your favorite agents
over time you might
use hundreds of agents.
So you need to use
something like LeanIX hub
to track the agents you're using.
So quickly to summarize the work on
to basically our vision of agents,
there's three parts again, right?
The first part again is
we want to empower businesses
with these prebuilt agents.
We have 40 agents that
are already out of the box
by the end of the year,
we want to democratize the development,
make it easy for you to
develop on top, right?
So the idea is that Joule
democratizes business applications
by letting users access
with natural language.
We're also here for developers,
democratize agent development
using Joule studio.
And then finally we
actually want to make sure
you can use the full agent ecosystem.
So we support A2A as well.
You work outside as well.
And so you heard, you know,
in the morning Matt
Garman is talking about
democratizing through platform, right?
AWS creates a big platform
for business applications.
SAP, we create the software on top
to also make it easy for people to use.
One other thing we've done
actually use AI Assistants.
I want to explain again,
we talked about how you have the LeanIX.
LeanIX AI Agent hub shows you, you know,
what type of agents you have
and that's for humans, very valuable.
It helps us to see how it's organized,
but machines also sometimes
need context as well.
You know, if you say, hey
can approve this process,
if you ask a question that's very vague,
it might not know what
you want to approve,
but what it can do is
look at the AI Assistants,
which we announced that
SAP connect in October.
We can know what persona you're in
or what lines of businesses
you're working on
and use that as a grounding
function of where you are,
by doing this so we can
scope down the work.
If you're a finance professional,
if you want an approval,
it would be something that
your CFO might approve.
If you're in procurement,
it could be a purchase you're approving,
for supply chain, you know,
whatever's appropriate.
These AI Assistants help you scope down
kind of your universe of agents.
As I mentioned earlier,
you have a bunch of animals in a zoo.
It's very hard to know.
But if you know you're
looking for giraffes,
you actually can actually
get a better answer,
you know what you're looking for.
So basically this is the same thing here.
And so Joule agents, as I mentioned,
both visually through
for humans through LeanIX
or through yeah, Assistants,
can actually help you organize
and segment the different agents
that you have to deal with.
And so the one thing you may want to do,
if you are interested in our agents,
we have QR code here as well as the URL,
I think this will also be
available offline as well
so you can actually certainly
have access to it afterwards.
Just wanted to share this
before I move to next section.
So the one thing that we do is SAP and AWS
have worked together for a long time.
We have a partnership for years.
And so one of the things
that we decided to do
is basically to help accelerate
the generic success for customers.
We power the software and we scale on AWS.
And the idea is that we have this
collaborative gradient agreement
where customers can
actually make a request
and have us help you
accelerate your onboarding.
And so we have, you know,
obviously our track record,
we have more 16 years of working together.
We have a lot of industry
and technical expertise
and then we have this global reach.
And so the idea is that you can reach out
and this unique path
lets you get started fast
and also is subsidized by us in AWS.
How does it work?
So basically you apply
to get into the program,
you have an idea,
and once you have your
program, we approve it,
you can accelerate your production.
So innovation comes through
SAP business processes.
We can actually, you know, as I mentioned,
scale it through AWS,
the adoption can run your
AI through our environment
with built in safeguards.
We have obviously
enterprise grade compliance
through AWS and through SAP capabilities
and the security that you've
heard about on both sides.
And then the agility increases too.
You can actually get a
lot more done with this.
And so the idea is you can get this done
as early as nine weeks.
And so if as any of you are saying,
"Hey look, I'd like to do this,
but I just don't have
the resources to do it,
don't have the ability to do it."
This is how you can do it, right?
So basically you make a request
and I'll show you the next
couple slides how to do it.
But the code innovation
process is very structured.
You have actually, we take the
first phase of exploration,
we look at key business
challenges and look at use cases.
And so basically you say,
"Hey, I have a big challenge,
a big pain point in my job in my company
and this is what it is.
Make sure it works."
Then we ideate this use case discovery.
We say, "Hey, do workshops with customers
together to AWS and SAP,
let's figure out how
to solve this problem."
And then we can have an architect come in
and help architect the right design
and then we can build it.
And so this whole process is actually
like assisted by us in AWS,
you can use SAP's generative AI hub,
which is our solution of the
40 plus large language models
I mentioned earlier
use Amazon bedrock capabilities
and then also Amazon Nova's
foundation models as well.
And then finally phase
five is the implementation
with all the security monitors
and guardrails in place.
So basically this is a five step process.
The first four steps
can pretty much be done
in about nine weeks,
as early as nine weeks
if you work in quickly
and you can actually need
formal ways to deploy
so this is a very fast process
and if you're interested in doing it,
as I mentioned, if cost is an issue,
it's a funded project
and I'll show you how to do
it and handle in a minute.
But summary, basically you
have inside out or outside in,
outside in you have SAP AI core,
which is our capabilities
inside the cores,
our generative AI hub,
which has a bunch of language models
included in our Amazon Bedrock LLMs.
And so you can actually
access their foundation models
from Anthropic as well
as Amazon's native ones,
which are Titan and Nova.
And the foundation models,
you can actually also
access Cohere Command,
Embed, or Rerank.
And so this is the technology you're using
and the process if you want to do is
you have to contact
AIProgramSupport@sap.com to get started
and as I mentioned, it'll accelerate
your journey AI development,
adopt advanced capabilities
and leverage our investments.
And this is actually doable
if you're an especially AWS ecosystem
or if you're trying to decide
if you want to use AWS and SAP,
this incentivizes you to do that.
And we have to helped fund, you know,
together with AWS, we help support this.
So it's actually a great opportunity
for on the fence of you know,
whether not to try it or not.
Okay, so I'll just summarize
kind of what I talked about
and some of the things
that I didn't talk about
but just the full picture of SAP
and I'll go love to write top to bottom.
So basically we talked about
agent to agent interoperability earlier
and MCP server support, right?
You can take the MCP
server wrap, your APIs,
can get access to it,
and then we can actually
allow agent to agents
to expand extend use and connectivity
to different API services.
More Joule scopes have been built.
We have over 2100 capabilities total,
which basically means in natural language
you can actually do a lot of things
with our systems across all
of our lines of businesses.
Two weeks ago we announced
that our ABAP AI model,
which is our fine tuned
domain specific model,
has been made available inside of,
will be made available inside
of our generative AI hub
for direct access.
So any of you not from the ABAP,
so our advanced business
application programming language
is our domain specific language.
And so if you use GitHub copilot
or any of these coding tools,
it doesn't really have ABAP covered.
So we fine tuned with
over 300 million lines
of internal code on ABAP
and built a fine tuned model on ABAP AI.
And so that model was available
inside the eclipse IDE
for about a year now.
But people said, "Hey, can
we have better access to it?"
And so now we're making it
available in in Gen AI hub
so it can be accessed in other
development environments as well.
So if you develop in ABAP,
if you have SAP developers,
you obviously can, please
have them use that.
Beyond that, we actually
are using that tool
also for code migration.
We are building a custom
code migration agent.
So any of you working
on a your rise migration
or updating your code can also leverage
this capability as well.
Lastly, in the first row,
basically these new mutual agents
I mentioned, we have
40 by end of the year,
but we have more coming as well.
And if you have specific agents
that we don't have on our roadmap,
you can reach out and tell me.
We can actually make sure
that we go, you know,
customize and make sure
you can get what you need.
Second row, AI Assistants
in the left hand side
is basically, as I
mentioned, the scoping down.
The idea that understanding your persona,
what persona you are and
what you're working on
could help reduce the scope
of what agents are activated.
And so the idea is that over time
there'll be more and more agents.
And so having ability to scope down
and help us figure out what you need.
The middle one, middle
box, is AI Agent Hub,
which I mentioned already with LeanIX,
where you can actually have
all virtual agents are there
custom agents that you build can be there
and third party agents as well.
That way you have easy
access to all of them.
Middle right is what we announced
at the beginning of November,
which is our first enterprise
relational foundation model.
So just to make clear,
in case you're not familiar with this,
basically people are built
building language models
and we built the first
business trans tabular model.
And so the difference
is basically if I say,
hey, it's cloudy outside today, right?
I say it's cloudy outside,
I'm going into closet to pick out a blank.
The model can either say,
let's say jacket or umbrella,
maybe 60% chance jacket,
30% chance umbrella,
10% chance anything else,
glasses or whatever.
But you don't really
think about that, right?
You just have a language
model, complete sentences,
but it's all probabilistic, right?
But when you're talking about
like your business processes,
you do think probabilistically, right?
Hey, I need to find enough inventory
for Black Friday shopping.
How many units of my
widgets should I purchase?
You know, it's also probabilistic, right?
Maybe 80% chance you need
more than a hundred units,
20% chance you need less
than a hundred units.
And so the foundation
model takes tabular data,
which is like Excel spreadsheets
or comma separated value files for short
and does predictions on them
the same way language is predicted
upon with large language models.
And we don't, may not
think of it that way,
but it's the same thing.
And so we use the same technology,
it's a transformer based technology.
And the reason why we can do is
because we have, as I mentioned,
data from all lines of businesses
as you've heard already.
And so we can actually
apply these foundation model
across many different prediction problems.
And the value behind this
is basically five years ago
when the first large
language models came out,
you stopped building narrow AI models.
No one builds sentiment
classifiers analyzers anymore.
I used to actually had to,
my jobs a few years ago,
I built a sentiment analyzer
for a quick serve company.
You don't actually ever
do that anymore, right?
You don't build summarizers.
People don't need to have
a team of data scientists
build summarizers.
The same thing happens here
with predictive analytics,
if you use this RPT-1 or
rapid one, as what we call it,
you can actually use one
horizontal tabular model
to solve a lot of different
tabular AI problems.
And so we gave it, it's
publicly available,
the playground, you should try it out,
if you haven't seen it,
we've given some examples.
But you can do a lot of different things
like examples of like extrapolation,
like if you have missing data,
I gave you an example about
transportation management.
If let's say you have a
table of like packages
and you have some missing data points,
like you ship the package
to me in Las Vegas,
you know, which, what's a shipper?
And you can actually use
a foundation model to say,
oh, typically speaking
packages shipped to Las Vegas
at this time of day or this time of week
are driven by this particular shipper.
And so those type of things
are available in this model.
So definitely try that out.
We're going to continue evolving that.
But it's basically, I tell
you kind of like a GPT-1
or GPT-2 moments in terms of
what happens type of models.
And so this is unique to
SAP so please check it out.
Bottom row, I'll start from left.
Our prompt to my service,
we made it also available.
We lets you change prompts
when you change different LLMs.
This is really valuable,
and you can also say,
"Hey Walter, I use bedrock only."
So, but it's fine,
you can also still use prompt optimization
across different bedrock LLMs as well.
If I'm using Nova and I've
been using it for weeks,
I modify the prompt
and then tomorrow I say maybe I should
try Anthropics Claude.
Well, if I take the same
prompt and move it over,
I'm not doing an apples
to apples comparison.
I use the analogy that you, may have kids,
I don't know if you have
kids, but if you have kids,
you raise them and you talk
to them one particular way.
And then once your kid's a teenager,
your teenager brings a friend
home to talk to dinner,
and then you talk to this person
the same way you talk to your child
and they don't respond the same way.
And you're like, I don't understand why.
It's like, because each person likes
to be responded to differently, right?
And believe it or not,
we don't want to
personify language models,
but the idea is language
models are trained on data
by different, mostly similar public data,
but it's all customized to each model
just the same way humans
are all different, right?
And so if you talk to two
different LLMs the same way,
you won't get the same answer.
So we built this prompt optimizer
to make sure we optimize the prompt.
That way you can actually get
apples to apples comparisons
if you're trying to switch LLMs.
And that's actually valuable
because the next step
we've already pre announced is that
we'll help you also decide
on LLMs in the future
that way give you more RRI to say,
"Hey look, this LLM is more
expensive than this other LLM."
And give with the same
return accuracies, right?
And so basically that's
kind of where we're leading
to this prompt optimization.
The bullet in between is basically
we have engage with Joule
and Microsoft 365 copilot
is fully integrated
because productivity
users and M 365 and SAP
have a high overlap.
So with one within one copilot,
you can access the other
one and vice versa.
And the value behind that is that
as kind of we talked about agent to agent,
is that we don't expect you as users
to go to eight different co-pilots, right?
I mean, if you wake up in the morning,
use one consumer co-pilot at home
to set your alarm when
you're cooking your eggs,
you go to work, use another copilot
for your productivity tools,
use Joule for your SAP tools,
use four from our co-pilots,
it gets old, right?
And so we want make sure
we're doing our best
to help make it as easy
as possible for everyone.
That's why we have this engagement
and we also why we support A2A as well.
And lastly, I think one thing
that's also interesting is,
you know, there's deep research now.
In the past, you ask a question,
you got an answer, you're done.
Now you can ask more
complicated questions, right?
Like, hey, I mentioned an example again.
I want to book a trip to see
my four, five biggest customers
and I want to make sure
it fits my schedule
and their schedules.
That's actually a deep
research type question.
We have this capability in Joule,
which goes deeper and says,
"Okay, I need to spend five
minutes to give you an answer,
but I'm going to give you
the itinerary for that process, right?"
So that example I gave from the beginning,
you can actually apply this
and ask these questions now
because deep research exists.
And deep research means
that each of these agents
can give you what can
figure out what it can do.
And it also knows what
other agents can do.
And in this example I'll give you
is basically again, you might say,
"Okay, I want to visit my
five biggest customers."
I go to my CX solution,
which is our CM solution.
It says, "Here are your
five biggest customers,
here's where they're located."
And then you say, "Okay, go to Concur
to find a travel and here's
a potential itinerary."
But then before you finish
that you actually go to
engage engagement with Microsoft
where you look at people's calendars.
Are people free? Are you free?
Maybe you have Thanksgiving vacation,
your Christmas vacation.
So basically there's
three different agents
if you are at play here,
going back and forth,
back and forth to figure out.
Okay, finally figure it out,
first week of December,
I'm going to "re:Invent".
Last week of November,
I'm at Thanksgiving.
But okay, second week go December,
I'm going to go to New
York first and then Miami,
third week I'm going to
be in LA, San Francisco,
and then my Christmas vacation happens.
So basically these agents
have using research
to solve a problem that you have
can give you the right answer.
That kind of summarizes
all the different things
that we're doing.
I know I have a few minutes left
so I can take time for questions.
And if you have some,
I'll repeat your question.